ja ich begrüße ganz herzlich zur
heutigen sitzung in der wir uns mit
guten hoffnung befassen werden es war
irgendwas morphologie bedeutet noch von
kobe genannte formen lehre ist deutsch
so viel wie die form weiß man hin also
griechischen die form
und griechisch natürlich logos ist die
lehre die lehre oder auch die theorie
locker es kann ganz verschiedenes
bedeutung als es die formen lehre könnte
sagen okay so und bevor wir jetzt aber
hier auf diese denker eingeben wollen
wir noch mal hier auf den deckel der
vorherigen sitzung ernähren zu sprechen
kommen wie heißt dieser denken
ja genau
noch weiter ein polyp genau und zwar
genau genommen ist es ein grüner ampel
so und wir nähern uns über die grünen
produkten und dem eigentlichen denke der
letzten sitzung wissen sie noch wie der
geheißen hatte diese nacht denke genau
das er ist und wer soll eine ganz kurze
zusammenfassung lieben über sein denken
dass bildungszuschüssen der bildung
streep ist hier im zentrum lukas theorie
des bildungsträgers besagt der betrieb
liegt jedem lebendigen organismus
zugrunde
er ist von bloss mechanischen kräften
verschieden also wenn wir jetzt wenn ihr
von kräften oder trieben reden müssen
unterscheiden zwischen organischen und
physikalische zb wenn ich jetzt eine
eine taschenuhr aufziehen die
fehlerspanne ist da auch eine gewisse
energie gespeichert
die kraft an während die federkraft
wieder konstant
aber das würde jetzt nur mit war von dem
betrieb die organismen zu grunde liegt
gerade
bildungsträger die werden so eine
unterscheidung zwischen großen
mechanischen kräften und lebendigen
organischen trieben häufiger im seminar
kennen werden weiterer punkt ist dieser
bildung streep bewirkt dass der
organismus gezeugt wird es überhaupt
entsteht nämlich durch die bildung
streeps anbieter dass das erzeugte durch
den betrieb erzeugt es sich am leben
erhält durch ernährung dass die notation
von der er spricht und sich selbst
regeneriert da spricht nun noch von der
reproduktion
ich hatte das ergänzend sind ziemlich
richtig verstanden
nach der reproduktion sei so viele
zeugen und spricht auch von
reproduktionen wenn sie zum beispiel
irgendwelche bienen oder sonstige medien
profi karriere aber eher produktion
passiert damit es nicht gemeint
vermehren sich mit der generation pro
generation sondern die region zum also
wenn zum beispiel diesen grünen
produkten einen hahn abgenommen wird
dann regeneriert der sich in der
ursprünglichen form vielleicht nicht
mehr genau so identisch aber auch okay
und zum schluss in dieser kurzen
zusammenfassung kann man sagen bacher
tritt gegenüber herde eine app wie
genesis theorie wonach äußere kulturelle
umstände erblich und zu einer anderen
natur werden und das fand ich besonders
spannend
das fand ich besonders spannend diese
epigenetische theorie die auch
kulturelle faktoren mit einbezieht
wenn sie den text ganz bis zu ende
gelesen haben werden sie sehen dass das
ziemlich absurd manchmal schafft also er
sprach davon vielleicht kann das noch
parat
also dass manche völker amerikas ist
also die eingeborenen also völker
amerikas dass die sich immer die
wahrheit heraus gezupft hätten sogar mit
muschel aus spitzen muscheln hätten die
sich den abgekratzt also richtig nicht
nur äußerliche geschnitten mit
rasierapparat unwirklich also wenn ich
die die wurzeln entfernt hat und er
schreibt dass durch diese häufige
entfernen der vorfahren der männer hat
werte durch diese tiefgründige
entfernung das dadurch deren nachkommen
würden war gar keine werte mehr bekommen
hätten
er bringt aber auch noch andere dinge
mit lebten und so weiter und so fort
ohren abstehenden ohren das ist
natürlich überhaupt nicht mehr haltbar
aber ganz falsch
bitte glaube ich nicht weil es durchaus
der biologie theorien gibt heutzutage
des während das kulturelle umstände also
kulturelle dass die auch sich irgendwie
dann ein schreiben in unserer natur und
sich zu tradieren ganzes an finde ich
hier den begriff der anderen und natur
das ist also intakt
nur waren an der relativ häufig wenn wir
auf eine zweite natur getroffen zwei
tagen zu viel wie die kulturen die erst
im oktober ist die biologische natur und
biologische beschreibbare und die zweite
natur ist häufig so dass kulturell er
spricht von der anderen natur damit
meinte dass eben auch die umstände
klimatischen kulturellen gesetzen
gewohnheiten dass die sich mehr oder
weniger auch in uns ein schreiben mit
genetisch und sich bewähren müssen diese
umstellung als beispiel bringt er eben
hier den die bahn halte ich nicht für
überzeugend aber in anderen belangen
gibt es ähnliche thematik epigenetik ja
wenn ich jetzt hier auf dem tablett
schaue sehe ich wir haben schon die vier
zuschauer
das ist sehr erfreulich die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer hier auf
den kanal sind herzlich eingeladen
kommentare zu unterlassen wie auch die
teilnehmer ihren seminaren und ich werde
darauf eingehen besonders möchte ich
einen erkrankten seminarteilnehmer
grüßen der hoffentlich jetzt von zu
hause aus dieses seminar wirtschaft
deswegen machen wir nicht auch im geiste
ja das machen wir jetzt auch immer
wieder denke ich weiß einfach ein
bisschen aktiv ist
so jetzt können wir zu diesem elitären
hier ist es kein grüner politik
sondern er ist es die wissens alle ist
könig johann wolfgang von goethe ich
merke mir immer diese jahreszahl 649
weil schiller das wissens 650 gewohnt
ist also zehn jahre jünger ist mit
diesen 49 59 kann ist es sehr gut und
johann wolfgang von goethe hat auch
einen interessanten text geschrieben und
mehrere texte geschrieben die uns
interessieren können und zwar die sich
an diesen formen lehrern die morphologie
und wir wollen uns heute voll
gefahrenstelle liefern sich goethe
stream und formen lehre zu derjenigen
bei herder und bach die wir schon kennen
gelernt haben weitere pflanzen liefern
wird den bildungsbegriff bei goethe eine
normative bedeutung verliehen mit normal
nicht in diesem ist mit bildung nicht
nur die ausdifferenzierung die
entwicklung die natürliche gemeint sind
auch so was wie moralische verfolgung
stichwort perfektion
das möchte ich auch noch mal kurz darauf
schreiben also wir müssen schauen wir
von bildung reden oder wenn wir von
solchen dingen reden bildung
man kann immer zwei betreten zwei dinge
bedeutet mindestens einmal so was wie
natürliche vermittlung
und zum anderen eben auch kulturelle
kulturelle fortentwicklung oder gut auch
perfektionierung
hier steht natürlich dann immer hier
auch die mobilität im zentrum
stichwort humanität davon sprach er da
die humanität ist nicht dasselbe wie die
menschheit
wir haben gesehen können menschheit von
menschlichkeit unterscheiden
menschlichkeit ist sagt diese normative
kulturelle seite und die menschheit ist
also die natürliche biologische seite
und ich glaube dass wenn wir jetzt auf
einen bildungs trieb reden als sie zum
ersten mal das wort bildungsklick sahen
blasen hörten dachten sie bestimmte an
der ziehung kulturelle bildung geht mit
ihnen zumindest zu einer bildungskrise
er ist ein prinzip in der was irgendwie
eine geistige entwicklung bewirkt und
das ist eben nicht mehr der fall
im zimmer diese doppelung diese
doppelung dass hier hier unten ist
leicht schreibt normativ normativ
bedeutet hier gibt es eine wertung der
mensch soll besser werden soll sich
vervollkommnen moralisch soll die
humanität das internet dem ideal der
humanität sondern mehr wäre natürlich
entwicklung des kreativ ist also nur
beschreiben schreibt keine wertung
diese unterscheidung möchte ich einfach
nur noch mal hier an verdeutlichen und
das hier ist ein
als bezogen auf die menschheit zum
beispiel und ist ihr unten wäre dann die
menschlichkeit menschlichkeit und daher
gibt es eine gewisse spannung
das sind nicht das hendl
also grob gesagt kurz gesagt alle
theorien des betriebes die wir jetzt
behandeln die schwanken zwischen diesen
zwei bedeutungen einmal die natürliche
deskriptive seite einmal eine kulturelle
im normativen warnschild
perfektionistische auch freiheit gehört
in diesem bereich die dieser spannung
müssen immer diese ganze theorien des
briefes verfolgen und dann haben wir
noch eine frage nein haben wir nicht als
liefe wird den industriegütern enormer
tiefe bedeutung verlieren schauen wie
kommentare haben
nein bisher noch nicht gut
ok dann noch die unklar folgen der
letzten sitzung bei blumenbar also die
letzten seiten dieses aufsatz der 70 die
waren etwas merkwürdig also dass
technologische wird nachdem angestellte
aber dennoch ist es immer der erde eben
epigenetische team vertritt also das
nicht von vornherein eine form
präsentiert ist schon gar nicht bei
allen der gewesen sind das ist die form
verändern kann und eben gerade auch
durch kulturelle umständen das ist
glaube ich sehr sehr die moderne
biologie erwägt solche dinge muss man
sich sehr vorsichtig sein
das nicht blöd wenn wir jetzt in
bestimmten umständen leben das wir dann
dass diese umstände in unserer den haag
übergeben aber sehen die natur ist so
flexibel dass alle veränderungen
irgendwie sich auch im nächsten
generation etwas machen können
und jetzt lesen wir von goethe auszüge
aus einem aus aufsätzen zur allgemeinen
pflanzenkunde ganz interessant goethe
konzentriert sich hier vor allem auf die
pflanze als nachtisch dass die unterste
stufe des organischen also darunter dem
anorganischen stehen oder wie sie alle
wissen steine kristalle reisen und das
organische beginnt eben auf der
untersten stufe mit die pflanzen
das ist alles alles tot ethische
ideengeschichte und sie finden dass ein
solcher schritt zu noch mal geben
jetzt aber immerhin kostet ein das ist
jetzt eine replik auf
also das chronologisch für er sagt so
viel aber getraue ich mir zu behaupten
dass wenn ein organisches wesen in die
erscheinen hervortritt einheit und
freiheit des bildungsträgers und dem
begriff der mitteilung versenden nicht
zu fassen sei so weiter zum schluss ein
schema weiteres nachdenken anzuregen das
schema sieht so also was das
haben sie dazu was diesem schema ist das
überzeugend und erzählt sie das
verstehen sie das schreiben sie es
[Musik]
wir brauchen auf der anderen seite
die volkszeitung
wie ein virus
dem spiel
so dass sie in der berichte in geballter
zusammen kommen also dieses potenzial
und dessen höhe von den großen vermögen
in der kasse ist
gut finde ich sehr einleuchtend also
hier ist die aristotelische dem
hintergrund nämlich dynamisch die
möglichkeit und die energie und das tut
was sagt wie sie wissen dass die dünner
mit die möglichkeit er mit dem stoff in
verbindung gesetzt wird also mit dem
material eine sauna des todes muss man
jetzt so verstehen muss ein guter stoff
können wir gewisse dinge frauen als ein
stoff ist nicht von vornherein die linie
da irgendeine für das heißt doch liegt
die möglichkeit ihr können
das und möglichkeit vermögen die mannes
hängen irgendwie der st unser ist der
stoff und forschung kommen mit ihr die
zusammen gegeben erst das ganze das ist
auch bei aristoteles so das ist der so
genannte höhle im office muss beschreibt
das trifft auch mal hin
[Musik]
es müsse zu mir kurz noch diese tafeln
wieder mischen mit
ein virtuelles schlagen das ist gelöscht
ich werde jetzt mal hier eine größere
schrift stärke und kehren zum leitwort
zum virtuellen weiten fühle ist der
stoff und muster kennt es wieder dass
die moschee ist die form so und nur wenn
wir diese beiden dinge nach alles das
zusammen bringen dann bekommen wir eine
substanz an individuelle substanz die
auch was durch das filmland sind ein
symbol und schön heißt zusammen
das zusammen sie können alle synchron
und ist das ganze sein zusammen ganzes
komplementär höhle ist und wie der
schule ist immer die möglichkeit die
möglichkeit mit dem form ist immer die
wirklichkeit
müssen also die möglichkeit in die
wirklichkeiten verführen und wie tun wir
das demir sie bestimmen durch die form
der hintergrund und das geld könnte
durchaus in diese trennung steht und als
der stoff und form sind komplementär
interessant finde ich jetzt die frage
wie das ganze hier in sachen hin
man kann durchaus sagen vermögen haben
wir mit stoff stand kraft auch stärke
gewalt ist jetzt in der mitte streben
und trieb ich habe es auch so
interpretiert gleich dass das alles
gewisse dynamische charakterisierung des
lebens sind mit leben und streben auf
der tagung über den begriff des triebes
mit klassischen deutschen philosophie
ich mache um rechten link zur playlisten
der videos vorträge waren wir uns auch
nicht ganz sicher wenn mit welchen
begriffen der trieb begriff den engen
verbindung steht kraft war immer zum tod
streben auch gewalt hatten wird er nicht
aufgebracht
aber auch die natur kennt sowas wie
gewalt und bis jetzt vermögen dynamik
sie hat anstreben
das scheint mir eine gewisse
charakterisierung sein die zwischen
stoff und form vermitteln vielleicht
könnte man es lassen sagte sie
[Musik]
stornieren
hmm
ja also ja das eine gute idee also der
einzige punkt wo jetzt nämlich ganzen
können wir in den kommunen werden heute
durch personen zugeschrieben lebewesen
also aber sonst stimme ich mir schon so
als er die frage ist was meinte goethe
das ist jetzt halt nur das kind also
klar ist diese diese mittleren japans
phänomene die sind von stoffen form
unterschiede sind eingespannt und das
ganze zusammen
der übergang von stoff zu formen oder
stoffen formen ihrer einheit vermittelt
durch diese ganzen phänomen überwinden
vermögen kraft gewalt strebt trieb die
ergebnis leben sind versuch einen
dynamischen lebens begriff zu entwickeln
überlegen sie mal wenn sie zb der statue
haben der staat steigt aus eisenerz dann
sieht das ganz anders aus
dann hätten sie zwar auch stoffen formen
und den stoffen sie reisen können sie
beliebiges einsetzen stein form hätten
sie die statue vor
aber sie hätten dann eben keinen fall
wir streben keine trieben der substanz
aber keine lebendigen diese substanz
organismus
ein weiterer punkt der mann die man hier
darauf werden muss es die frage wie sich
was jetzt mit leben gemeint ist wenn wir
deutschland von leben sprechen dann
meinen wir meistens das leben genommen
das alles im blick das scheint er hier
nicht zu meinen sondern erscheint hier
konkrete einzelne dinge also organismen
zu nein ich gebe mir kurz einen like wir
haben jetzt schon viel besser gehe
machen sie die fleißig sind es schon
sechs zuschauer
sieben zuschauer du liebe güte das ist
ja wirklich
und jetzt also das finde ich ganz so
kann man es erklären
das möchte ich aber noch mal hier auf
dieses diesen auf diesen satz da voran
gehen nämlich er sagt er spricht von der
einheit und der freiheit des gelöst das
sind ganz neue begriffe die blumenbach
sogar noch gebracht hatte sich nur mit
bahr sprach nie von freiheit kein
einziges mal meine
und von einheit auch nicht goethe bringt
jetzt hier neue begriffe ins spiel die
dem begriff des bildungsträgers weiter
anreichern und er sagt jetzt wir können
im bildungsbetrieb nur da bildung streep
begriffen und dann verstehen richtig
wenn wir ihn mit dem begriff der
metamorphose in verbindung bringt goethe
möchte hier in diesen texten das begriff
des bildungsträgers weiter bestimmen
indem er ein held der metamorphose dazu
ein spielbank
das heißt mit einer hose und bildung
streep hängen ganze mit einem gesamt
jetzt ist natürlich die frage hat das
meint jetzt hier gehörte mit der
freiheit des bildungsträgers ist nicht
alles hier schon von vornherein
determiniert da könnte man auch sagen es
im genetischen code dritten stammzellen
usw alles schon vorher terminiert pre
terminiert wo ist da überhaupt noch
freiheiten spielen natürlich im blick im
fernsehen entwickeln sich doch nicht
rein
das könnte goethe damit das ist jetzt
das kleine fragen was meinte hier mit
freier sie wissen der freiheitsbegriff
ist unglaublich wagen
wir können auf alles mögliche hier
beziehen also meine these ist wollte das
goethe damit so was wie eine autonomie
und selbstbestimmung der organismen als
organismen haben gewisse ziele gewissen
vorgaben und
diese vorgaben diesem zwecke liegen in
den organismen selbst die werden nicht
von außen an sie herangetragen
jeder organismus hat eine eigene form in
dieser form möchte möchte gang
verstrichen wir wollen ich muss jetzt
aufpassen nicht begriffen spiegeln diese
diese diese form soll erfüllt werden
durch weitere entwicklungsstaaten und
dieses streben nach inneren zwecken
das kann man mit einer gewissen
berechtigung als freiheit bezeichnet und
es mit der hand noch mit der
selbstbestimmung
damit ist natürlich jetzt nicht dasselbe
gemeint was wir heutzutage und der
autonomie verstehen wenn wir heute von
autonomie sprechen dann meinen wir damit
verantwortungsvolle entscheidungen
aufgrund von abwägungen gründen so was
findet natürlich mit pflanzen nicht
statt
aber was bei pflanzen stattfinden müssen
ist eine große einheit spricht die
pflanze versucht gewesen ihre form
aufrecht zu halten noch vor allem
natürlich an
die einfache organismus und sie versucht
eine nebenher in taylors ein zweck
gerecht hieß es dem inneren prinzip
gerecht werden das kann man mit einem
gewissen recht als schwarzen wir jetzt
autonomie bezeichnen denn sie sich dafür
weiter interessieren können sie von hans
joas aktion hast meine ich hans jonas
ein buch sich mal anschauen oder ein
aufsatz ich bin immerhin hans jonas
das heißt organismus und freiheit
und freiheit
und da sagt hans jonas organismen in
organismen finden märz die erste spur
von feiern
es steckt schon etwas weiter und diese
freiheit die nimmt natürlich zu je
komplexer die lebensform also einen
ganzen harem schon gewissen grad an
autonomie andere lebewesen natürlich
noch viel mehr und wir haben eine
autonomie die so ganz so
individualistisch ist dass wir uns gegen
unsere eigene natur denken können dass
mit ihr tun können die uns war natur
abträglich sind zb die zuviel chips ist
das würde andere lebewesen vielleicht zu
nicht zu uns wir sind so frei dass wir
dass unsere freiheit gegen unsere natur
wenden kann was bei anderen lebewesen so
nicht möglich zu sagen ich will jetzt
auch gar nicht weiter spekulieren aber
wenn sie es interessiert diese these hat
hans jonas in verschiedenen aufsätzen
weiter es gab also leben und den look
streep kann man nur verstehen wir mit
geliebte metamorphose betrachten jetzt
spricht goethe hier von den
metamorphosen der pflanze
offen wenn wir jetzt einmal
textabschnitte hierdurch sagt ein leader
der das wachstum der pflanzen nur
einigermaßen beobachtet wird leicht
bemerken dass gewisse äußere teil der zu
heben sich manchmal verwandelt und in
der gestalt der nächstliegenden teile
der ganz bei mehr oder weniger so
verändert sich zb meistens einfache
blume dann in eine gefüllte wenn sich
anstatt der staub fäden und streute
blumen blätter entwickeln die entweder
an gestalt und form von kommen den
übrigen blätter deckungsgleich sind oder
noch sichtbaren zeichen ihres ursprungs
kann sich trauen
wie verstehen sie dieses beispiel ganze
idee was sie gemeint sind
wir haben acht zuschauer das ist der
bisherige rekord der heutigen sitzung
was ist damit gemeint dieser dieser
veränderung von der hier spricht oder
verwandten verwendung das ist natürlich
nichts anderes als zum hoffnungs kommen
was könnte er hier denken gerade 1.2
statt diesen stoffen gesprochen
genauer und allen diesen formel ist ein
gewisser und genießen ursprungsform
immer noch erkennt nicht erkennbar
zeichen des ursprungs also wissen sie
noch um welche pflanze goethe als die ur
pflanzen angesehen hat wissen sie was
wissen sie dass ich versuche es immerhin
zu machen
ja genau
sieht es einigermaßen richtig aus bisher
ging komplett gegen konkurrenz und damit
hat er nicht ganz unrecht weil ginkgo
ist ein uraltes gewächs das gab es durch
reisen für befinden jahren millionen
jahren schon während unserer eiche
revolutionär sicherlich für juli und das
ist dieses denken dass hier urformen
das ist jetzt alles noch recht vage
lesen wir weiter was sie noch von goethe
gesagt wenn wir nun bemerken dass auf
diese weise der fernseher möglich ist
einen schritt rückwärts zu tun und die
ordnung des wachstums umzukehren so
werden wir auf den regelmäßigen blick
der natur desto aufmerksamer gemacht und
wir lernen die gesetze der umwandlung
kämen nach welchen sie einen teil durch
den anderen hervorbringt und die
verschiedensten gestalten durch
modifikation eines organs der stadt
interessant finde ich hier die rede von
den regelmäßigen naturgesetze der
umwandlung und diese diese umwandlung
kann nach vorne oder nach hinten das
zurückgehen engagieren sind gewisse
gesetze stadien oder momentan
entwicklung umwandlung ist natürlich
gerade hier mit der matrose und dann
sagt er dass diese verschiedene
gestalten durch die modifikation eines
einzigen organs dargestellt alles was
jetzt dieses organ das ist ganze pflanze
und die pflanzen zu löschen
die modifiziert wird wir sind weiter
also noch so die geheime verwandtschaft
der verschiedenen pflanzen als der
blätter das geld der grund der staub
werden welche sich nacheinander und
gleichsam aus wenn entwickeln ist von
den forschern im allgemeinen längst
erkannt ja auch bereits besonders
gearbeitet worden und dann hat die
wirkung durch ein und dasselbe und gar
sie uns mannigfaltig findet die
mithaftung für müssen sie komplett
stifter 210 organ damit meinte
wahrscheinlich organismus
minute stand
als organ heißt eigentlich nur so viel
wie werkzeug griechisch vorgenommen
und können
dazu
zurück
also ich glaube er meint damit das organ
ich verstehe es jetzt diesen fünf
abschnitten verstehen
ja
tragen
mai
es gibt es eine art einheit gute möchten
in bildungsstätten übernehmen von
buchenbach und dieser bildungschips
fundiert könnte man sagt im organ
organismus und diesen individuellen
lebendiges substanz und dieses substanz
dieses organ das wird modifiziert dass
modifiziert sich muss man genauso und
dass sich modifizieren
das kann man auch so verstehen dass sich
das ganze selbst bestimmt nämlich zu
gewissen form entwicklungen hin und
dieses sich selbst bestimmen könnte man
als selbstbestimmung oder als autonomie
oder auch als freiheit fast gewissen
rechten also das zeltlager und zwar nach
bestimmten gesetz bestimmt bringen jetzt
zeigt sich uns diese art metamorphose
diese modifikation des organs nach
bestimmten gesetzen organismus auf teil
art regelmäßig unregelmäßig und zufällig
also so viele gesetze spielen nicht
immer eine rolle
die regelmäßigen metamorphose können wir
auch die fortschreitende
sie ist ist welches sich von den ersten
samen blättern bis zur letzten
ausbildung der frucht immer spur von
weise wirksam bemerken lässt und durch
umwandlung einer gestalt und andere
gleichsam auf einer geistigen heiter zu
jedem gefällt der natur der
fortpflanzung durch zwei geschlechter
hinaufsteigt diese ist es wichtig
mehrere jahre aufmerksam beobachtet habe
und welche zu erklären ich gegenwärtig
versucht unternehmen
wir werden auch deswegen bei der
folgenden demonstrationen die pflanzen
oder zu fall betrachten als einjährig
ist und aus dem saarland kommt zur
befruchtung unaufhaltsam schreitet also
wege mal bezahlt jetzt wie charakter
sieht jetzt gute diese regelmäßig mit
dem fuß
das ist damit gemacht
nehmen sie diesen text
schneider gehörte wird
dieses turnier ist erfreulich
duca
also
fortschreitenden bedeutet dass es sich
so eine gewisse dass immer mehr heraus
entwicklung geht
ich möchte eine geistig begleiter und
geistig geistige leitern oder jetzt
natürlich und dementsprechend geist
geleite
naja
auch in derselben reihenfolge also
generation er regelmäßig das meint der
jahren oder puncto e mails werden
nutrixxion und zufällig wäre dann die
reproduktion die regeneration
das scharf zurück
es ist einfach ein bisschen mehr
und das was er dazu fähig gezeichnet
okay okay diese andere natur von der
spricht ja also diese umstimmt die dann
den bildungs trieb auch so ein bisschen
von außen beeinflussen
andere meinung dazu für eine gute idee
dass auf wunsch auch direkt zu beziehen
halt das wäre jetzt die seite generation
sich die regeneration generation die
fortpflanzung und das sagte das sei ein
gipfel der natur
warum ist sind die fortpflanzung durch
zwei geschlechter hier muss man
überhaupt sagen es gibt doch auch
phänomene wo sich organisiert selbst
gefunden das ist ja bekannt das phänomen
also warum müssen dass hier zwei
geschwächte sein kann man sich wirklich
fragen
das müssten die vielleicht damals nicht
was was steckt dahinter
haben sie eine idee warum sollte das
jetzt bitteschön die der gipfel der
geistigen seite
das könnte dazu konnte das sind gedanken
ja durchaus als ich denke das ist
sicherlich richtig und ich glaube dass
vielleicht ja auch sein wissen mit der
physik der leber bei goethe
herunterspielen könnte das ganz vom
menschen hier sollte es überträgt auf
das pflanzen
ja
richtig
ja also auf jeden fall kann man sagen
nur ausgewachsene individuen können sich
fortpflanzen also ganz frisch
geschlüpfte küken könnten wir können es
auch nach der geburt und pflanzen wurde
auch nicht wenn du nicht ausgebildet
sind noch keine irgendwie hier blühte
man sowas haben schreiben entwickeln der
ersten betriebe nöten wenn sie in diesem
alter haben diesen status
insofern könnte man sagen muss einer der
organismus zu seiner blüte gekommen sein
wie man so schön sagt ja bisher eben
dann dass ich vor greift und das ist
also eine die unregelmäßige metamorphose
könnten wir auch die rückscheibe nehmen
dem wie in jenem fall die natur vorwärts
zu dem großen zwecke der reproduktion
muss man sagen dass der abbestellung von
fortpflanzung in alt trifft sich hier um
eine oder einige stufen zurück wie sie
dort mit unwiderstehlichen trieb und
kräftige anstrengung die blumen bildet
und zu den werken der liebe rüstet das
war mein verdacht dass sie eine mit halb
sieben im hintergrund steht denken sie
an das symposium von
klar denken sie an der kugel menschen
kannst du mal gelesen diesen mythos von
aristophanes schwer auf diesen konten
mensch muss schon wieder hier eine
wirtschaft die tafel zwischen sozusagen
also wird das ist ein ganz ganz tolles
und wichtiges werk von platon von goethe
kann das natürlich darüber dass sich die
situation
die richtige besitzer ist das trinken
nicht das gastmahl
aber indem diese mit diesem dialog von
plato da geht es richtig zur sache
da wird nicht hier wäre es gibt es keine
feine manieren sind daher wird gebechert
und da wird auch gibt es anspielungen
sehr also auch ein bisschen entwicklung
aber es waren eben die alten griechen
und das heißt nicht dass sie durch den
politikern im gegenteil sie waren sofort
ohne und hier ist eben das stichwort der
heraus er ist nah und der rest ist also
eigentlich auch so was wie ein bildungs
und könnte man eigentlich ein
vereinigung stream
dies sage er was uns hier gibt es an
einen mythos also diesem trinke dass
jetzt mehrere personen philosophen
sokrates darunter zusammen trinken
fleißig und halten reden auf den airbus
es geht um die frage was ist servus und
aristophanes bringt da eben einen mythos
vom coolen durch
menschen bekommen das besagt
ursprünglich gab es nur google menschen
des wahren leben wesen die eben vier
arme für beide hatten unsere köpfe immer
mann und frau praktisch mit dem rücken
zusammen gewachsen und die haben sich
dann zu formen in dem sie räder
geschlagen
die haben also weiße mitglieder haben
die ganzen fortbewegt und weil eben die
menschheit aufbegehrte gegen die götter
wurden sie dann keine bitte und zeigt
dem sie diese getrennt wurden besuchen
die immer wieder gestellt
das ist das und versuchte erklärung der
geschlechter das ist natürlich den
geplanten des mythos das ist eine
metaphysik sind prinzipien und dahinter
und das scheint mir hier auch so ein
bisschen zu grunde zu legen wenn jetzt
hier ein goethe von den wehren der liebe
sie würde nicht sagen dass fließen sich
leben oder selbst würden sie das auch
nicht sagen bei ganz einfachen
lebensformen die sich frau pflanzen
würden sie doch bestimmt nicht sagt dass
die liebe wurde spiel zu müssen die
betriebe oder revolutionären vorgang
sexualtrieb uns
liebe kommt darin nicht vor das heißt
hier ist nur gewisse metaphysische
begriffen ist
ja verklärter begriff der liebe im spiel
merkte die größte werk in der liebe was
würden sie darunter verstehen
fortpflanzung ein werk der liebe ist die
fortpflanzung
wenn ich alles etwas zu tun dass es den
anderen besser bin gut das wird für
pflanzen nächsten analysen der
arbeitgeber nach so dass die pflanzen
gegenseitig wahnsinn zu konferieren
fallen werden und ihre nachbarn in
versen zu beginn der regenzeit bedarf
werkstoffen zu ende
ja also gut oder pet als einfach die
zuneigung die dann aber irgendwie auch
in die reproduktion führen so erschlafft
sie hier bei der mine 7 gleichsam und
lässt ohne schloss in geschäften einem
unentschieden weichen unseren augen auf
gefälligen aber innerlich und kräftigen
und unwirksamen zustande
durch die erfahrung welche wir an dieser
metamorphose zu machen gelegenheit haben
werden wir das wenige türen können was
ist die regelmäßige verheimlicht
deutlich sehen was wir dort nur
schließen und auf diese weise steht es
zu hoffen dass wir uns absicht am
sichersten
also die these ist in der unregelmäßig
mit einem kloster zeitlich unsere und
prinzipien klar als sie es uns zeigen
bei der regelmäßig anrufe müssen
dagegen werde von der dritten
metamorphose welche zufällig von außen
besonders durch insekten gewirkt wird
münster auf
am kai track werden weil sie uns von dem
einfachen fliege welchem wir zu folgen
haben ableiten und unseren zweck
verrückten könnte vielleicht findet sich
an einem anderen ort gelegenheit von
diesen monströsen und doch in gewissen
grenzen ein schreck geschwenkten
auswüchsen zu sprechen
das müsste es jetzt wieder google bach
erhöhen die monstrosität
das war also dieser bildungs blieb der
vergrößerung stellten beeinflussen
wurden das war auch ein bisschen was was
vielleicht epigenetisch bezeichnet
werden kann
da sagte sind insekten hast du gute hier
nicht berücksichtigt scheint mir dass er
gerade für die fortpflanzung entscheiden
sind aber es gibt ja auch fälle wo
vielleicht ich blüten gegenseitig
gestorben haben wo der sprühten stoff zu
behandeln fliegen das sollte es auch
geht die zecken transportiert wie das zu
vermitteln
aber es scheint nun auch politik zu
gehen zu nehmen
natürlich okay die teilnehmerzahlen
nimmt ein bisschen ab wir haben jetzt
immer vierten von acht auf vier
wir haben wir gerade und liebe
gesprochen seltsame ich habe es gewagt
ging wir den versuch ohne beziehung auf
erläuternde kupfer auszuarbeiten kupfer
was ist damit gemeint der leute haben
die kupfer
verstehen sie hatten keine zeichnungen
beide leben keine skizzen
die jedoch in manchen betrachten möchte
ich behalte mir vorsehen der folge nach
zu bringen welches umso bequemer
geschehen kann
da dort noch stoff genug übrig ist
gegenwärtige kleine nur vorläufige
abhandeln zu erläutern und weiter
auszuführen es wird als dann nicht nötig
sein sohn gemessen schritt wie
gegenwärtig zu halten ich werde wenn
jetzt jemand herbeiführen können und
mehrere städte aus gleichgesinnten
spritzen gesammelt werden eben rechten
platz stehen besonders werde ich von
einem gleichzeitigen meister die ehre
sich diese edle wissenschaft zu rühmen
hat gebrauch zu machen nicht verfehlen
diese demo bieten sie mit gegenwärtigen
dass das ende dieser untersuchung
also wir sind wir sehen hier spricht
verschiedene formen der mit einem fuß
aber was genau ist sagte uns jedenfalls
stellen wir fest dass goethe gewisse ja
vielleicht sogar anthropomorphe
anthropomorphe eigenschaften in die
natürliche entwicklung hinein beziehen
das scheint mir sehr interessant sein
dass er diese weise diese natürliche
entwicklung doch vom menschen her sieht
das mit anthropomorphe muss manchmal
centris muss gerade seine familie
spricht oder 53
das sind eine prädikate die nur menschen
zu kommen zumal wieder acht zuschauer
lustig so als er musste für hier einmal
zerstritten ist okay und jetzt kommen
wir zu weiteren interessanten
begriffenen konnte vermelden
schneider im typus weiße gestalt muss
man jetzt abgrenzen verformt und typus
auch das ist die spannende frage was der
unterschied oder wie verhalten sich form
und gestaltung typus zueinander
gestalten morphologie
diesem auto noch rote auf der
überzeugung dass alles was sich auch
andeuten und zeigen müssen von den
ersten frischen und chemischen elementen
bis zur geistigen äußern und das
männchen lassen wir diesen grundsatz
gelten also hier zieht sie wieder
das ist wie bei hertha wir haben wir
hier eine gewisse bei gewisse ja
aufstrebenden reihen
wir haben hier wieder um diese linien
und hier oben steht irgendwie der
menschen dass es hier unten stehen
wahrscheinlich wieder was auch immer
vielleicht haben wir ja mal die pflanzen
es gibt so eine fortentwicklung bis zum
menschen dagegen ist das geistige er
sprach vorhin bei der geschlechtlichen
vereinigung oder liebe davon dass hier
auch schon dass geistiges im spiel sein
das war gewusst dass geistig jetzt das
nach oben
also vermögen die fünfte reflexionen
selbstbewusst sagt freiheit so was dass
geistiges oder finden wir das nicht auch
schon etwas unteren stufen ja logisch
oder nur lieder oder sogar jeder nase
ist und eigentlich rede von freiheit von
geist oder liegt der tatsächlich
geistiges vor
nicht so in so besonderem maß wie es
beim menschen
wenn wir uns gleich zu dem was gestalt
hat das organische das wehgetan tiefe
dass anni mal das menschliche deuten sie
sich selbst alles selbst an deutet sich
das selbst alles erscheint als was es
ist unser größter unserem inneren sinn
hier ist jetzt nicht wissen rangfolge
wieder angelegt schauen sie er spricht
von organischen den meditativen
problematisch wenn wir das machen was
ärgert sie das ganz klar ja genau das
ist er hatte das heißt wir müssen hier
noch etwas mehr und das organische dann
sagt er hier dass das vegetative das
vegetative und dann kommt dass anni male
also tiere hanni made und dann kommt der
mensch ja frage die immer hier ist
endlich einmal rationale kannst du hier
bleibt alle denken dass die antwort
darauf schuldig ob der mensch ist ein
tier ist natürlich ist der menschen
bildet passiert ist ganz klar irgendwie
nahe dazu jedoch noch stärker grenze zu
ziehen
was verstehen sie unter deutet sich
alles selbst an
wie würden sie diese these nach modernen
begriffen der philosophie bezeichnen was
unternimmt hier gut davon gestalt was
ich was erscheint mit seinem begriff des
erscheinens mal bleiben welche
philosophie position richtet sich gerade
nach dem was den computer spricht
erscheinen
ja genau die phänomenologie das könnte
scheint ja auch das wesen das erscheint
das muss zum ausdrucken
scheidung
also mit gewisser weise kann man von der
feinschmecker die gestalt ist ein
bewegliches komme definition ein wert
und ist ein vergehen des gestalten wäre
ist verwaltungslehre die lehre der
metamorphose ist der schlüssel zu allen
zeichen der natur also gestalten nichts
fixiert es unveränderlich starres
sondern gestalten sind prozesse also
goethe möchte jetzt hier folgendes
zusammendenken ich gebe mal wieder weit
hafen und wird es immer ein bisschen
wieder schnell so vorgeschrieben so
schrecklich güte sagt jetzt
er sagt jetzt gestalt
gleich
dann könnte man gestalt jetzt definieren
müssen sie die revolution hier aus der
tasche
ich gebe meinen vorstoß des tages
eingestellt ist die einheit in der
vielheit
kannst du das einfach oder findest du
das konzentrations so schnell nur
vorschlagen
bitte auf youtube es ist ohnehin weiß
ich jetzt hier stand es dürfen gerne
schadens münchen aber geben sie in grund
und
und da ist auch verschiedene momente
diese stadion dass ich keine
[Musik]
ja also mit mir kam es deswegen weil sie
obwohl es sich diese pflanzen häufig
verändert
andere formen ganz anders aussieht als
am anfang aussagen wenn sie noch kleiner
war und so weiter ist es dennoch die
selben platz derselbe organisiert es
geht also auch um die frage der
identität
es geht um identität und identität wird
bewahrt wird
im wandel und diese bewahrung der
identität die natürlich immer lebhaft
ist realität wird im trieb in
verschiedenen ausformungen trieben immer
noch beibehalten weil eben gestalt so
ist dass sie nur bestimmte formen
annehmen kann ja alles ist nicht gleich
beliebigkeit
dass jetzt darüber los also eine pflanze
der atx die hat nur ein begrenztes
repertoire an formen die sie annehmen
kann also mit nico kann ich plötzlich
eichenblätter den chorraum kann ich
plötzlich reichen blätter hervorbringen
das geht nicht ein zitronenbaum kann
keine äpfel herausbringen er verteilt
werden und wenn sie drohen bauern
verschiedenen stadien sich anschauen
finden sie heraus dass die staaten sich
ziemlich ähnlich sind also da gibt es
mögliche wandeln und dennoch ist alles
selber ganz die distanzen staaten
durchläuft so werde ich jetzt gestaltet
in gestalt ist eben diese einheit die
alle modifikationen allen vier seiten
der form zu grunde legen und sagen was
die vielheit der form nicht die
beliebigkeit
es ist kein können nur bestimmte formen
angenommen sie sind vorher vorgestellt
haben und diese form können
unterschiedliche weisen durchlaufen
können sich oben bilden vielleicht wird
zurück nach bestimmt je nach
umweltbedingungen kann es ja eine
pflanze zurück mein ton baum den ich von
meinem nachbarn bekommen habe
er habe damit er mich erfriert der wirft
jetzt plötzlich alle blätter und die
zitronen werden jetzt auch so langsam
sieht völlig anders aus als der
freundlichkeit ein nutzer würde sich
goethe zu schopenhauers die welt als
wille und vorstellung äußern gibt es
starke unterschiede oder für die frage
ist zu weit möchten stören ja viel dafür
die anmerkung bei nämlich wie sie
vielleicht wissen
schopenhauer ein ganz großer freund von
deutsche verreisen
schopenhauer war mit seiner mutter
häufig zu gast
schopenhauer hat meines wissens auch
seine dissertation über die vierfache
wurzeln zu erreichen konnte goethe
geschenkt also schon mal als mutter war
immer in diesen ganzen kreise sehr gut
unterwegs war und so und insofern hat
meines wissens schopenhauer goethes sehr
sehr behindert und hier gibt es auf
jeden fall bezug zugute
es ist nicht so dass goethe was den job
mauer denke ich hatte er vor maurer hat
was goethe schon mal ganz gerührt wenn
ich mich nicht täusche bisschen und wir
werden diese frage am ende des seminars
das sitzung der des sozialplans also
ende des semesters weiter nachgehen wenn
wir auf schopenhauer zu sprechen kommt
für den wäre besser zu machen
auch von dieser grundausrichtung scheint
mir dass schopenhauer geht es sehr sehr
positiv gegenüber
steigt weil er auch im vitalis tisches
durchgeben
eine schrift die welt als wille und
vorstellung dass alles auch sehr und
betrieb habt ganze welt liste triebhaft
alles strebt und manifestation eines
willens und dieses dieses vitalis tische
moment befinden wir auf jeden fall auch
gekürt wir gehen genauer darauf ein
interessanter hinweis auf diese zeit
also gestalt an der jetzt verwandlung
der schlüssel derzeit natur güte wie
viele seiner zeit verstehen die natur
als ein zeichensystem das hermetisch
verschlossen werden
wir brauchen den hermeneutischen
schlüsseln wir brauchen den zugang und
das buch der autorin ziffern zu können
ein schlüssel zu schematisch analyse und
natur die natur mit allen sinnen und
zeichenhaft verstanden die sich aber
eben nur über bestimmte begriffe
bestimmte kategorie c fans und diese
kategorien mit denen jetzt geglaubt
dieses buch der natur entziffern zu
können
die sind eben gerade gestalten lehrer
metamorphose diesen begriffen möchte für
die natur verstehen interpretieren
wir betrachten den organischen körper
insofern als seine teilen form haben
eine gewisse entschieden stimme
bezeichnet und mit anderen teilen
im verhältnis stehen alles was die form
des teils zerstört was die muskeln
muskelfasern zertritt dass die knochen
in gerthe auflöst wird von uns nicht
angewandt nicht als ob wir jene weitere
zergliederung nicht kennen wollte und
nicht zu schätzen wissen sondern weil
wir schon in dem wir unsere
ausgesprochen entwickelt für ein großes
und unbegrenztes tageserfolg
also diese teilen stehen mit antworten
verhältnis des alkoholismus also das
samt hält diese wechselwirkung wir
können teile nicht isoliert betrachten
so nur im kontext des ganzes in
journalismus schreibt auch immerhin
alles muss
und es muss und da strich leben drin das
britische france ist ganz das leben das
teil nicht alleine für sich steht sein
stimmung bekommt sein zweck bekommt ist
nur der koordination der abstimmung auf
andere teile und das ist eben gerade bei
lebewesen besonders der fall
das ist die realistische ist ja das was
die form des teils zerstört was den muss
konsequent wenn es nicht angewandt also
wird jetzt praktisch keine analytische
analyse kann er gliedert der analyse der
pflanze gebe sondern eher eine
synthetische analyse nicht das ganze
auflösen in beziehungslos teilen möchte
eben diese teile in ihren verhältnissen
er möchte ein großes unbegrenztes tage
werden sie es geht es aufgabe der
ökologie physiologie schwebte menschen
als ein zweck vor der vielleicht nie zu
erreichen ist ihre dienerinnen wäre ich
im einzelnen fürs arbeiten sind
naturgeschichte welche den ganzen
vorlagen mehrere weniger ausländer die
naturgeschichte zusammenstellt und
besonders die kennzeichen ihrer äußeren
gestalt wie möglich macht so vera
programmatik um die anatomie becht im
inneren zusammenhang des gebäudes leben
über anatomie des menschen und der tiere
also anatomie heißt ja eigentlich nur
was heißt denn an atonal wissen sie das
was anatomie eigentlich wirklich
bedeutet
tomi das praktisch der aufschnitt als
praktisches aufschneiden
das passieren anatomie die mediziner
weil die lehrer die währungen oder wären
dann beziehen sie sich auf unsere
inneren gar dadurch gibt es verschiedene
schnitte doors und was nicht alles
wir können eben uns verschiedene
dimensionen zerschneiden diese schönen
grafiken in solchen körper atlanten habe
ich mir gerne die neuesten computer
techniken laden uns das ganz flexibel zu
machen
eine tomographie bogen von schnittbild
geben dass reformen ausschnitte von uns
fertig werden die anderen abschnitt als
aufgespielt aufgeschnitten dass also das
innere
aber eben auch über den zusammenhang und
nicht nur die einzelnen teile separat
was soll da eine leber oder am herzen
und so das ist nicht einer domina goethe
und ich glaube auch nicht mehr genau dem
verständnis sind es kommt immer darauf
an dem inneren zusammenhang klar
darzustellen und die naturgeschichte
dagegen ist nicht so sehr das wirklich
wäre gerichtet sondern auch die ganze
natur geschöpft als mehr oder weniger
was es alles gibt es auch und
technologien können es gibt diese tiere
diese diese augen und sofort und ihr
auch eine phänomenologie könnte die
haben bestimmte gestalt
so ist gibt es eine reihe von
kommentaren einen youtube nutzern streit
von aristoteles kennen wir dazu gehören
spielt dieser gedanke haben eine rolle
in seiner morphologie genau dass berto
also ergon heißt ja auch werk alles hat
sein werk und sie wissen alles total es
war ein großer theologe das thema das
thema das ziel zweck und david dass es
ärger mit hängt damit zusammen dass das
werk auch das wozu etwas ausgestattet
ist und ich wie schon davor sagte glaube
ich dass aristoteles allen natur lehrern
die sehr juristisch sind es sehr
[Musik]
ökologisch vorgehen muss dreieck bleibt
wiederum gibt eben zwischen
anorganischen und sag mal so gewusst wo
die seele in verschiedenen stufen haben
neben die vegetative seele das tierreich
daneben die bewegliche oder erkennende
wahrnehmen dem serienteil die tiere und
eben dem erkennenden oder rote block aus
menschen
das geht alles jetzt endlich doch auf
aristoteles zurück und jede
technologische natur lehre bis starke
australische befasst und deswegen würde
ich sagen auch diese ganze diskussion um
dieses argument
zur politischen rat von der rampe
drittels sagte chemie
das ist jetzt etwas anderes die chemie
trägt die verschiedenen stoffe auf und
jetzt ist die frage die kriminalistische
oder ist die chemie nicht nur an der
allgemeinen natur besonders weg der
lehre von der bewegung so ono mini
betrachtete organischer natur als ein
belebtes ganzes ihre betrachtungen sind
teils physiologisch teils psychologisch
wie die installierten physiognomik
betrachtet gestalt sofern sich diese
eigenschaften andeutet man könnte es in
diesem jahr zig welche den physischen
teil behandelt und ihn eigentlich
physiognomik welches sich des geistigen
und sittlichen teils annehme einteilen
was ist das problem eine physiognomik
das sind alles genau so
genau all die physiognomie ist praktisch
die lehre von der äußerlichkeit die
physiognomik die wirtin schritt weiter
und da haben sich beziehen
wir haben sich bezogen die versucht wie
soll ich sagen schlüsse zu ziehen
von äußerlichen merkmale auf nämlich
inneren begeistern oder sonstigen da
gibt es ganz in dieser zeit bei der sehr
häufig vertrieben worden hat aber große
probleme sind das problem dafür zu
sorgen
genau
ja und es geht eben soweit das eben im
19 jahrhundert da sogar das ganze
ziemlich ja sag mal missbraucht wurde
diese physiognomie während physiognomik
weil man eben versucht hatte nicht nur
jetzt irgendwelche einfachen
eigenschaften abzuleiten
mit ein mensch mit einer großen nase ob
die energischer ist weiß ich nicht
glaube ich nicht mehr
man könnte vielleicht sagen durch
gewisse gleich mit sagt gar nicht
spekulieren
aber es gibt gab da ein und denke da
ging es so weiter dass der chip rose und
er hat er werke spiel das heißt er der
geborene verbrecher
wo modelling quente ist der italienische
titel und der hat die these vertreten
dass wir wirklich männern vor allem zwei
männer dass wir den wirklich ansehen
können ob sie verbrechen und verbrecher
haben eine ganz klare einem körper
phänomen china das ging so weit dass
manche gesagt hat man hermann der
handschrift bei wika follow me h an der
handschrift schon verbrecher erkennen
wie sie schreiben bestimmte buchstaben
wurden erschwert ähnlich aussehen
er hat sogar die these vertreten dass
wir am gang von also der gang spur von
oben betrachtet die füße so besetzt
während die schuhabdrücke dass wir an
diesem tag schon differenzieren können
zwischen rosenweg geladen werden als
absurd diese theorie deswegen ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein
der damaligen zeit wagt so eine theorie
die häufig vertreten haben diesen allen
ist unsere absicht noch die cities
morphologie entspannen die morphologie
hinzuzusetzen die sich hauptsächlich mit
organischen gestalten ihrem unterschied
ihrer bildung und umbildung abgibt die
morphologie ist jetzt alle disziplin
diesen ganzen kontext der resident der
physiologie so sehe ich also physiologie
ist der überbegriff sagte hier die
physiologie
die ehre von der physis reise von der
natur die natur liebt die natur lehre
zerfällt in dieses 7 disziplin
die sind diener welt sein
wissenschaftspolitischen naturgeschichte
anatomie chemie allgemein natur lehre
zur omi physiognomik und eben zu guter
letzt die morphologie wie sie ihr team
auf ließ sich von den übrigen arbeiten
wissenschaft unterscheidet mit einem
deutlichsten eingesehen wenn wir
betrachten was sie von einer jedem nutzt
und welchen nutzen sie ihr dagegen
wieder gewähren kann
frage an sie diese naturwissenschaftlich
gebildet sind ja welche dieser sieben
disziplinen ist denn heute noch
überhaupt
aktuell gehen wir noch mal zurück gehen
wir alle durch hier naturgeschichte ja
schon oder kommt seine evolutionstheorie
oder zur anatomie ganz klar chemie
allgemeiner natur lehre kenne ich jetzt
nicht könnte man aber leben zu ohne mir
gibts sowas zu uns
also sorgen ist das lebewesen ökonomie
ist eben noch das gesetz als die nähe
von dem gesetz unternehmen werden also
dass er es sagen wir die ökologie
heutzutage weil das beliebte ganze die
ökologie lebensräume
nicht nur einzelne aber sein den
zusammenhang das wäre ökologisch während
mögliche physiognomik das geht überhaupt
nicht heute richten sie mal einen
lehrstuhl für physik es wird nur mit
komik wenn dann lernt sie hier die
verschiedenen nasen arten und soweit ich
weiß nicht was die ohren arten und du
hast dich für charakter nicht auszugehen
dass das bedeutet es ist also kommen
nicht weiter ja und wie sieht's mit dem
off erklärung könnte es davon heute eine
wissenschafts entsprechung geben oder
ja richtig richtig war ich glaube die
hat keine zukunft muss ich leider sagen
liebe güte ich glaube diese überlegungen
auch die ganzen des betriebes
wir sind mit sehr aktuell mehr
mitzutragen
wir haben darüber geredet was entspricht
der bildungs widerstands dna zuwachs kam
der bitte muss es eine entität die da
postuliert wird auf die wir aber gut und
gerne verzichten könnte heute geschafft
meine these das ist ihr so eine gewisse
philosophische interpretation der natur
die aber sehr berechtigt ist weil sie
eben diesen schön übergang von den
bloßen der ersten
nun zur zweiten guten zeiten kann und
das schafft nicht das will sich moderne
biologie videos gar nicht sagen aber die
sind so weiter sind wird es vielleicht
versuchen zu reduzieren aber ich glaube
dass hier wirklich ein großer vorteil
diese kluft zwischen geistes- und
naturwissenschaften zwischen erklären
und verstehen erklären wäre das was die
kinder hier
diese trennung dieser auftrag ist das
erklären wilhelm dilthey weil ich schon
gehört bild mache ich auch mal hier
kurzen bezug einkürzen detail hat die
unterscheidung eingeführt zwischen
erklären und verstehen
die zeit
den namen bestimmt schon mal gehört
gelesen sie haben wahrscheinlich davon
sprechen dass aus aber es war ein
bisschen deutschland haben gilt bei dem
19 jahrhundert gelebt zwei selbst
jahrhundert unterschied gemacht zwischen
erklären verstehen
ja und verstehen es auch den wir sind
das ganze und erklären wie er die
funktion zu und analyse und hier kommen
die ihr gehört die naturwissenschaft mit
dazu und hier gehören eben die
geisteswissenschaft
ob diese unterscheidung noch haltbar ist
sozusagen ist es ist strittig
alles ist sehr plausibel aber schauen
sie das legt auch den verdacht nahe dass
so etwas wie ein exakter exakte
wissenschaft geben die exakten
wissenschaften erklären könnte
quantifizieren und die und exakt in
diesem geist geschaffen
aber jetzt gibt es eben neue tendenzen
wie zum beispiel digital humanities oder
die die die digitale analyse
das heißt wir können auch methoden des
erklärendes der naturwissenschaften
übertragen auf geister und statistische
analysen machen von literarischen texten
das kommt uns natürlich wieder
interpretieren aber ich glaube dass
diese trennung nicht ganz so stellt halt
da ist also das rückblickend hier eben
ich glaube die morphologie hat in den
modernen wissenschaften so kein platz
mehr
aber er ist trotzdem philosophisch sehr
sehr ist von der ganzen natur geschichte
die im c die morphologie die kennt seine
gestalten im ganzen und dank hier die
bequemlichkeit die naturprodukte inhalt
der gewissen ordnung schnell übersehen
zu können
dagegen lässt sich die man von ihm nicht
jene die naturgeschichte in das einzelne
ein film erhält sie sich besonders
anfangs b klassen und deren hauptanteil
künftige ausarbeitungen wir auch
erlauben werden weiterhin abzustatten
sie bleibt sehr auch der auf der
abstrakten ebene von arten und gattungen
geht nicht selbst individuum das wundert
mich jetzt war jedoch eigentlich immer
so ein bisschen die einzelpflanzen
beschrieben hat med trust oder hingeben
der heimathistoriker hingegen nimmt
zudem morphologie und seine zu wort wenn
schlanke gestalt und in verlegenheit
setzen wird sowohl in absicht auf
kenntnis als aus ordnern manche beihilfe
bei dem ofen finden als jetzt geht es
hier sagt um die wissenschaft
theoretische kooperation gerätes zu
bleiben also wie bekommen wir ordnung in
dieses gefüge in dieses uhr
übersichtliche wird von gestalten der
natürlichen den 2 als also eine art
arbeitsteilung also der natur ist wohl
ja sagt er
der überblick ganz schnell
aber er lässt sich in das einzelne 1
während dem mauerfall die sich nicht auf
das einzelne einlässt sondern eher auf
diese klassen und arten leben blickt
also eher ein bisschen abstrakt könnten
die und gestaltung die phänomen ideen
oder das verhältnis genau bestimmen kann
ist nicht so ganz klar oder
was ist der unterschied zwischen natur
geschichte und noch etwas ist ja
praktisch ihr habt ja
was ist draus zu machen
die als große ökologische
es ist eine art es ist so so eine
versuchung
deswegen war es okay das tor geklaut als
lassen könnten wird das schlechte
stimmung seit die morphologie betrag
einfach den großen zusammenhang der form
über dinge die isoliert nicht nur
einzelne lebewesen ihren momentanen
stadium sind sie hatten überblick die
ganzen gestalten die individuen
durchlaufen können
und wenn dann eben jetzt hier eine
gestalt gefunden wird lässt sich ja
nicht gleich immer sagen wozu gehört
aber müssen ja nicht alle formen die die
gestiegen ist individuell möglich laufen
kann überblicken für eine ganze reihe
muss dann zu machen dh der natur ist die
natur geschichte die neben los isoliert
sequenziert ist genug benannt oma
isolieren und der morphologie der kann
immer ein in die ganzen anderen
phänomenologischen ausgestattet
das sieht ihr den übergängen
verschiedene fragen nicht nur die
einzelnen themen das wäre vielleicht so
kontextuelle natürlich nicht
individualistische von dem anatomen hat
der mann flog viel zu lernen und zu
nehmen
die übersicht der teile der äußeren
inneren ist er ihm schuldig und die
vergleichen derselben in den
verschiedensten naturen wird ihm
erleichtert mai mit der natur um fühlen
muss dass es sich in seinem eigenen
reichtum gleichsam verbirgt so gibt der
morphologie im anlass seine schätze zu
ordnen und zu stellen damit der große
vorrat übersehbar wäre der monolog ist
es der den vergleichen
familie gründen muss ok ökologie ist
immer kontextuell politisch immer im
vergleich man könnte sogar auf seiten
noch von dies vielleicht zu einem etat
wissenschaften also eine wissenschaft
die immer dass einzelne kontextualisiert
ist ein orden
was überlegt weil es sind möglich über
die verschiedenen formen hat die
verschiedenen zwischen leader der
veränderung die das konto
so können was außer diener die
morphologie ist die wissenschaftler die
das die natur dem gesichtspunkt dass
kontinuierlich des wandels betrachtet
während die natur lehre die
naturgeschichte hier eben immer nur die
natur sondern könnte naturgeschichte
die betreffen die natur so als
nebeneinander von entitäten während die
morphologie eben die natur ihren wandeln
ihre übergänge macht es hier mal solches
sagen das ist mir so was du also ganz in
der dynamik versucht zugreifen
dergestalt wären dann also nicht nicht
isoliert kontextuelle solistisch und das
hier wäre isolieren
nun versuchte alles es geht hier um eine
wissenschaft für den naturforschern in
dem der morphologie allgemeine und
besondere gesetze bewegung indem er
erfährt dass in der organischen natur
sich manches auf mechanisch gesetzt
zurückführen lässt
das würde desto mehr von dem eminenz des
lebens überzeugt welches über ja auf die
mechanische gesetze
diese unterscheidung zwischen
natürlichen trieb und mechanischen
gesetz mit den kräften kennen wir schon
von diesem denken war
die hatte auch gesagt dass es simon
mechanischen goethe versucht das jetzt
aber eine gewissen zusammenhang das
sehen kann sich als die der organischer
natur manches auf mechanisch gesetzt so
führen jetzt was sie zum beispiel zum
beispiel der wasserdruck in togo das
könnte was mit michael
der wasserdruck in pflanzen salz und
sole druckverhältnisse könnte etwas
mechanisches wasser
in einer tabelle effekte könnten
physikalisch küche an
während eben ja auch photosynthese zwar
ist die frage aber diese übergang ist
die frage nach dem übergang von physik
chemie und biologie dass der entscheidet
über wie kommen wir von bloss weil ein
physikalisch beschreibbare der phänomene
hin zur biologisch an dieser übergang
ist eine moderne wirtschaft nicht ganz
nach extrem schwierig
von der atomaren struktur zur
geologischen struktur dann zu den un zu
kleinen organismen wie eben das los
atomare sich in der zusammenfügung zur
lebendigen entwickelt das hat in der
naturwissenschaft immer nicht gezahlt
und drehen sich auch die frage wer sich
hier gut mit
übrigens hält sich der physiker dass er
im allgemeinen und in organischen auf
als das der morphologischen sollte ihm
sämtliche dienste leisten zu können
das haben wir gerade gesagt der physiker
der betrachtet eben nur die tote materie
das anorganische oder das organische
oder im gesicht des anderen geben unsere
moleküle auch und nicht uns gedacht wir
sehen schon die photosynthese ist wenn
man sie physikalisch bestreiten extremst
komplizieren
sie müssen ja die photonen dann
realisieren auf diese mikroskopischen
ebene können wir fast neben
zusammenhänge gar nicht mehr
also das ist praktisch jetzt auch der
schlüssel unseres seminars der heutigen
sitzung und gültig fasst zusammen gute
versuche den bildungs trieb von wohnbau
weiter zu bestimmen
die einheit hier waren die wichtigen
begriffe einheit
aber vor allem gestalt ich habe jetzt
gestaltete typus so beschrieben als es
die einheiten der vielheit ist also
trotz dieser verschiedenen formen die
ein individuum anorganischen die
wiederum annehmen kann bleibt es doch
dasselbe über die zeit hinweg
transparent identität danach goethe noch
wissenschaftstheoretiker oder mit
wissenschaftlich versucht die
morphologie diese formel lehrer
einzuführen und in einem verbindung zu
setzen in anderen bereits zur damaligen
zeit etablierten wissenschaft
disziplinen für den einige aber wie wir
gesehen haben eigentlich gar nicht mehr
nicht mehr haltbar ja also ich denke das
ist das interessante der umsetzung
gewesen
ich bedanke mich finalrennen
seminarteilnehmern ich bedanke mich bei
den youtube zu schauen
die hier fleißig kommentiert waren und
auch gesagt haben wir haben ist seinen
stand 11 marx das bisherige rekord zu
vielleicht lieben bekommen
in der nächsten sitzung werden wir uns
mit
andere denker befassen auch den auch ein
sprung ein bisschen vor auf den auch
goethe zu sprechen kann
in dieser kurzen blick auf das war immer
anerkannt also kant und goethe sind
zurzeit müssen aber armut zu wenig ruhe
gehabt und deswegen werden wir jetzt
zwei sitzungen der für die sache machen
kannst widmen
und wir werden jetzt einen übergang
machen hin von der biologie der natur
lehre hin zur moral verkannt nicht nur
von bildungs drittes er spricht sondern
von einem triebfedern und jetzt werden
diese ganzen ried ganze redeweise
vertrieben und bildung wird jetzt aufs
individuum dazu kann spricht ich mir so
viel von pflanzen tieren der betrieb auf
den menschen und das ist eine
entwicklung die bike an den ausgängen
und die dann dazu führt dass fichte zum
beispiel später davon spricht dass die
freiheit des menschen trieb das was wir
anfangs an was gar nicht so viel
miteinander zu tun hat was gut ist ein
bisschen erwägung gezogen hat das hält
wichtel dann vermutlich dann wünschen
noch einen schönen rest woche bis zur
nächsten zu kommen